in youtube audiences and then we'll
begin the session
all right
very good
and welcome everyone
to our career master class uh preparing
your career for machine intelligence
4.0
and our guest today is prasad chita who
is the
ai ml practice lead in the banking
financial
services and insurance sector for
contact consultancy services
and i will introduce him shortly but
first
for those of you
unfamiliar with webex controls please
enter your questions for
sod into the q a
i will collect those and
get those to him during the q a portion
of the webinar toward the end
uh you can also direct the chat to all
panelists so we'll see that
but um
we generally will hold the questions
until the q a section
and
we'll also be doing a couple of polls
during the webinar
so i'd like to start with this first one
and bear with me while i get it started
so this first one is just basically
about you and your level of experience
and how you're feeling today um
we do that second question
to check in with people during
the pandemic period
see how people are holding up to the
stresses of
lockdowns and
booster shots and things like that so
just take another few seconds and
respond to the webinar
question and
here we go
so
i'd say that this
audience as you can see is
weighted toward people who are still at
the school
we do have the next largest group of
people about a quarter who are
seasoned professionals in the
10-plus years
of experience category
and it's good to see that
most of everybody is either doing well
or
doing okay
we hope that the information in this
webinar will help to
improve the outlook people who are
not feeling as
bright today so
with that i'm going to go ahead and
introduce
prasad
uh
who as i mentioned is the ai and
practice manager
ai and ml practice lead rather at
total consultant services in the banking
financial services and insurance sector
a digital solutions architect a data
philosopher
with
nearly three decades of experience and
he provides high-level
services to
global
enterprise customers
in machine intelligence which is
one of the fastest growing and most
exciting sectors in the digital economy
today so
welcome prasad and thank you for being
here
and you're on mute so you might want to
meet yourself there you go
thanks start
[Music]
so welcome everyone
to this
webinar
uh i
will share a quick
uh
few slides
yeah
so yeah before we
start so this
is not much of a
seeing content it is more to
hear
listen to it and
try to understand
the current industry
where it is going
and
and to
see how we can prepare and what is
happening
in the world
so we
look at preparing yourself for the new
normal new normal or
the machine intelligence 4.0 so
typically when we put these version
numbers at the end of the
at the end of the at the end of anything
so it should have a context so we'll try
and understand a bit
of
why it is 4.0
and how it is changing the
[Music]
the carriers and how it is impacting
different roles across the industries
and what we can do to
kind of prepare ourselves into
into this
4.0 world
so
uh
we will
at the end of the session you all will
understand what is mi 4.0 and then
what are all the skills needed to make
machines intelligent
then i will provide you some kind of a
small
self-assessment framework saying that
how to
look at
driving our own one's own carrier in
this
in this
arena of fourth generation mission
intelligence
and readiness and transforming for a
experienced professionals how they have
to look at it are there either
people coming from a different
industry or different uh
career path into
machine learning machine intelligence
are pressures
who are trying to that is the majority
of the population i see
from the
poll
so
that is what we will achieve that before
we go into certain questions and answers
you can whenever you have a question you
can put it into the box
ah we will uh address them as they
come
once we finish
the discussion about the basics uh what
we wanted to cover here
so the context of what is 4.0 many of
you may be aware that there is a
industry 4.0 which is going around so
the first
stage of industry is a mechanical
revolution
started by the steam engine invention of
the steam engine
then the second one is an electrical
revolution the electricity
going around and making
mechanical
devices work
without steam
so that is the electrical revolution
the third one is the internet or the
information revolution
where the information is available
everywhere
and the fourth one
there is no name to it that is called
fourth industrial revolution
i like to call it as cyber physical
systems so basically
we are connecting the systems to talk to
systems people to talk to systems
and
system to talk to people so all sorts of
connections are happening and
we call it as industrial iot
machine learning cloud
all these
social media
connecting on the networks
massive online courses
helping everyone all these things put
together it is the fourth industrial
revolution it is combination of
bringing cyber physical systems together
so parallelly on the
globalization and the political scenario
we have the
like collaborative environment then the
rise of patriotism
make my country great again this kind of
campaigns and
there are
several fair economy environmental
concerns uh social and work impacts
which we see
we call this
political and
economical system scenario as
globalization for artwork so that is
also is available there
then
came the pandemic
what we are going through
there are multiple waves of pandemic we
are seeing and all the work moved to
remote
so
this is the current context
where we are
where we are in
so then
we generally to handle this businesses
who are
looking at
taking this fourth generation industry
in fourth generation globalized
environment
they have to get
their machines
work intelligently so machines could be
software systems robotic systems
whatever it is
so
what are the fourth
generation the four generations of
intelligence from the beginning of
software field we see machines being
intelligent so the first generation
intelligence is
programmed
so
what people programmers have done is
they have written several decision
making statements if then else while
some loops and stuff like that so the
decisions are taken based on the
programmed constructs
then to improve
the intelligence in the machines there
came the erp systems uh
sap south the world and oracle systems
so with a configuration how
it has to behave the behaviors of the
systems have changed
so that we can call it as the second
generation of the machine
intelligence
then came
a non-programmed
intelligence so this is where the
machine learning
machines started learning from the
examples instead of
a programmer programming explicitly what
is to be done
a programmer has shown the past examples
of the data
and
pro a program learnt
what to do with the data and apply the
same knowledge
when the similar data is presented to it
it will predict a score or it will tell
uh what is to be done what decision need
to be taken that is what typically known
as machine learning
or the data scientist driven machine
learning
those are the third
generation three generations of machine
learning but for the fourth generation
what is needed
is
we have to remove or reduce the
dependency of data scientist creating
these learning systems
the cloud
the providers now coming with a concept
called auto ml automatic machine
learning and continuously learning
generating multiple learning models and
multiple learning agents and teach each
other
in an automated fashion
and
make the whole process autonomous
that is the
key thing
where we are moving on to
in the fourth generation of the machine
learning
so
overall the goal of fourth generation of
machine intelligence is to develop
learning machines
from
multiple methods of learning
there are
methods of supervised learning
unsupervised learning semi-supervised
learning self-supervised learning
and continuous basis to
extract knowledge and use the knowledge
to build on that knowledge
to
make machines behave intelligently
adding the cognitive capabilities like
vision
language
understanding language generation
all these things putting them together
into one place and making them
autonomous and continuous learning
machines
this is the goal of fourth generation of
machine learning
so let us move quickly to see
uh
what is the impact of the tmi 4.0 on
different job roles
so typically what is businesses are
looking for employing this automation
for two things
uh one is to improve the selling
remote selling or
taking the products to the public
two is
once we sold a product or a service
make that product or service is
available to that deliver them service
them
operational efficiencies how we can
efficiently achieve the operations right
from logistics to
customer service
in this process
how do we
make
use of the
fourth generation machine intelligence
and most of the software jobs so
basically software aids
different
business functions to become more
cognitive more intelligent and
more efficient
and all the projects within the software
are being
managed in an agile fashion so there is
nothing like
a waterfall
model of software development
most of them are gone into the agile
fashion everybody is doing a sprint
uh
developing products developing
um
full stack developers uh automated
devops these are all the standard
practices in
software project development
devsecops are whatever
the integration of operations and
development together testing everything
in one pipeline
so the cyber physical systems
are in demand
so production of these cyber physical
systems is
happening with a continuously evolving
technology we have seen
pi torch
tensor flow multiple tensor processing
systems gpus tpus
different types of processing units
the algorithms like
gradient boosting machines
back propagation second order methods
and a lot of research in computer vision
um
and also in the natural language
processing are the big companies
the large
social media companies are pioneering
this work with
multiple language models bi-directional
transformers and stiff stuff like that
so as a overall
movement of the carrier like
full stack development was uh
the trend
until
uh
a few months ago
or few years ago
so the back end front end developers all
these things are merging into something
known as a full stack development
now
the trend is moving to something called
full stack deep learning so currently
there are rules like
data scientists machine learning
engineers
data engineers or stuff like that who
are handling the data pipelines who are
bringing in the data from the source
systems to the learning systems
and those who are making the learning
systems work
and those who are actually developing
the science behind them
applying statistics
so the whole of this is going to
converge into something like a full
stack deep learning
so that is the impact on the job roles
going forward in my opinion
need not be
a industry opinion from what i see
then
how
do we train machines to be intelligent
so
as i mentioned there are
things the business challenge is the
first bit here so businesses wanted to
improve their key performance indicators
they wanted to optimize they wanted to
innovate and they wanted actually to
be excellent or beat the competition and
be excellent in their own business these
are the key challenges
they drive
certain tools to actually process the
stream store and learn from the data
data which is structured which is
unstructured which is pictures or which
is
blog posts news articles market
movements whatever we look at as all
these data is publicly available and
with cyber physical systems lot of iot
right from
everybody's shoes
and
health monitoring devices wrist watches
and
these things collecting the information
pushing into the cloud information is
available
with the consent
somebody signs into a service
somebody accepts that their data can be
processed
how do we make best use of that data
so the enablers for that are the actual
people the intelligent people
typically
programming in one of the languages try
to write the intelligence in a
programmed way now
we are writing or we are trying to make
trying the machines to be intelligent
let the machine let the software
learn
so i see different people the
researchers who are researching on a
deeply into one subject how can i
improve object representations of a
picture
from a
video how do i get a three dimensional
object representations from a video
to aid a self-driving car
this kind of research
is happening
in the academic institutions and the
bigger labs
then we have these seasoned data
scientists who are aware of a business
domain
there are ml engineers
who can make the tools and platforms
work they can install tools they can
make the platforms piping done and they
can get the data they can get the
training
they can validate the models
do the feature engineering all these are
the different skills of the ml engineers
the data engineers are helping to
convert the data to model ready
deal with the raw data and
convert it into something a model ready
things
so beyond this
what are required some soft skills are
also required
the storytelling
and some hard skills are also required
the fundamentals foundations of
statistics
linear algebra
understanding how business operations
work
what are all the complications of
running a specific logistics business or
insurance business or
a bank
or any other uh business what are those
kpis
uh also understanding the architectures
of the systems software systems how the
software works
are
supporting hardware cloud data storage
and stuff like that
so what all these things are trying to
do is
to analyze visualize make sense of
create graphs or create semantic
understanding from the raw data
enrich the data make it understandable
both to human beings
and
the machines
so that is the challenge what we have
a lot of unstructured data
how do i make
it meaningful structured and put it into
a pipeline
through
and learn and do the predictions
prescription
describing the data and generating
intelligence from it
is the
crux of it so there are algorithms
obviously on the platforms tools and
algorithms as we talk
right algorithm to write type of data
how we can fit all this together is the
key ingredient or the skill of the
all these enablers
are the roles or the people who will
play this important role of
making machines intelligent and that too
autonomously intelligent
then
i will provide a bit of a
assessment framework
you can self-assess yourself basically
using this framework
so there are few criteria i have listed
which i think are very important for
this fourth generation machine learning
on this column
and
the levels of maturity what you think
where you are
so don't just choose a carrier
because it how it offers you good
monetary value
because this
you have to be with that carrier for at
least
20 30 years
um
as we work work through
these uh
area the future uh is definitely into
the
machine learning machine intelligence
there are going to be more intelligent
machines
so
it is
what is required here is
the passion to certain level of maturity
of the skill so the combination of the
skills are
very important
so i am a statistics specialist i do my
phd in statistics i can solve anything
in the start a statistical problem
that alone will not help
that need to be combined together
with an amount of either programming
language
or
an amount of operational
knowledge
of domain operational knowledge
to put together all these things
and
impact give an impactful solution in the
area of machine intelligence
so
the fundamentals are the statistics
linear algebra and the
basic knowledge of how to up how the
algorithms and optimizers work
in using numerical methods how do we
optimize a mathematical
equation to get to a best possible
solution
and what type of data structures can be
used to make those algorithms more
efficient how do we deal with huge
amount of
data
so those are the fundamental things
coming to the programming languages
there are functional programming
languages like python so the evaluation
of
programming languages is from the
standard c c plus plus to
c to c plus plus or java the object
oriented languages then we have
more functional languages like python
so
the functional languages give more
natively
support to learning and dynamism
are required to program the machines to
learn uh take the dynamic learning
then on the business side uh
understanding of business processes and
operational uh
tools used in the
tools used in the
automation of learning process itself
then
visualization visual the
communication skills that includes the
user experience understanding what type
of user experience is needed
how the intelligent mission can
communicate well uh with
the other machine or other person or
whom we are dealing with that user
experience
so predominantly there are two
career streams one is the data scientist
focused data scientist is a domain
knowledgeable person
the problem solving is there in the data
scientist thing
and ml engineer focused is more
technology oriented making the platforms
work mating making multiple clouds come
together providing the right security
connecting all the pipes and making the
whole learning process work so these are
the two
primary streams but they converge at
some point in time as a full stack
deep learning engineer or something like
that
so take this framework try to see where
you are how to fill the gaps there are
various ways of doing that which we will
discuss
in a while
and move the carrier
into the machine intelligence
so okay
for the freshers
the simple suggestion
to take the fundamentals in the
statistics probability linear algebra
as the first step
then go on to learn a programming
language and tensor processing
frameworks like tensorflow pytorch
psychic learn there are other tools are
available
then get into a specialization of one
business domain or a problem domain a
nlp process so try to make
language understood and
sentiment
kind of deriving the sentiment from the
language or the text
blogs summarization that kind of set of
projects or that kind of skills
are the computer vision based
skills or into enterprise
structured data based forecasting market
data analytics
risk
analytics fraud management that kind of
things
so what
refreshers can do is
learn hands-on learning
use the computation sites like kaggle
that is one of the suggestion
along with the
theoretical learning assignments
get on to some computations
use publicly available
platforms like google collab everybody
is using but make best use of them
go through the courses which are
available online
to upgrade the skills obviously there
are several courses which are available
you can choose based on your own
self-assessment saying that where you
want it to go
then don't do one-time assessment you
have to continuously look at
assessing yourself once in six months or
so that is how the
whole thing is changing nowadays
and also there are lot of open data
sources and there are lot of data signs
for good kind of a thing where you can
participate
[Music]
and provide solutions to the tough
problems sometimes the problems which
are available in the public domain with
the government data and stuff like that
so this is how
you can
make yourself ready for an industry
job
getting some experience of
practically solving
a
problem uh in using machine learning it
is not theoretical machine learning you
know you know i i know statistical
methods i can do a
logistic regression i can fit a model
here
i have done a
standard project quote unquote in
some pothole detection on a
road or something like that which are
typically available a lot of code base
is available on github
so
that won't help much unless you take a
problem take a data
source
and try to fit your own model optimize
your model you will see the different
steps of
making machines learn and making
machines learned continuously
then comes
the area of
how we experienced professionals can
move
their career
into the fourth generation of machine
intelligence
so we can see the
different people who are on the edges of
this machine intelligence trying to come
into the core of the mi folder tool so
data analyst business analyst current
analytical roles are
one thing so the analysts
they need to focus on learning
algorithms and a bit of programming to
become
data scientists
so
from a business analyst to data
scientist
the gap to be filled or the bridging
that whatever understanding of the
algorithms
at least mastering few algorithms for
example a gradient boosting machine
so people can try and understand how
what is boosting and how the boosting
mission will work and then from there
you can further
move to a
much wider problem solving model
so currently people are data engineers
probably doing etl
bringing data from one source system
transforming it putting into a data lake
or a data warehouse
they can actually learn tools to do
learning uh platforms
on cloud
various learning platforms making them
work the mlaps pipelining tools
experiment tracking tools model
management tools
model deployment and packaging
frameworks like django flask
and
most importantly the dockers
the containerization
[Music]
and the kubernetes the clusters how to
expand the clusters how to deploy a code
on the cluster execute on the pod and
stuff like that
so they can
become ml engineers by doing the
transformation
then comes okay already i am a ml
engineer how do i
become much higher on the ml architect
or a ml solution provider
a combinatorial skills between that this
is the
pathway to the
full stack
deep learning kind of a model
so understand deep learning so what are
all the different layers different types
of neural networks
ah
recurrent neural networks lstms
and various other
neural networking
based
algorithms how to train a pre trained
model
how to debug
some of the
deep learning
uh training code or whatever it is
and on a larger scale uh
into the overall end-to-end mlaps
things
moving that you can move into a ml
architectural
so one thing i wanted to cover is if
people are coming all the way from
completely different domain
like either a civil engineering or
any other business operations or stuff
like that
definitely there is a scope because for
the
from the business or domain aspect a
data scientist is having a scientist
and data together
so we
you can be an expert of some field or a
scientist in some field
you acquire the data skills and convert
data into a machine learnable features
and features into a representation of
knowledge
and that knowledge into insights
which can drive some business decisions
so this whole process any transformation
can help be either a data engineer or a
ml engineer or a ml architect
or a
full stack deep learning developer
so there are a scope so you can have to
use the same assessment framework
and see
where your passion is driving you to so
you choose a carrier that where you are
passionate of where you wanted to add
value into this intelligence pipeline
so you can take that and move on to
there a lot of
courses are available so you pick it up
from there
so
that is what i have as a monologue now i
wanted to open it up for
questions uh
that's
wonderful and thank you for for that
overview because that
it takes all uh takes us kind of
all the way into
what practical steps people can take to
um
become
uh professional in this in this area and
i like the fact that you
covered
the transitions from other areas as well
so i have uh
some interesting
questions uh
you mentioned enablers things that will
help
people
become
or develop their skills in
machine learning and
intelligence and ganesha asks if you
don't have access to those enablers
uh is there a way to start your project
what what what path can you
follow and is it possible to develop a
fully functional
mi system
on your own
okay
it is not possible that way so
definitely you would need
a set of people who will define the
project
who will define the goals of the
learning and where the data is coming
from
these two things are required a data is
needed a pipeline of converting this
data into machine learnable vectors that
is what we call them as from these
vectors into a learned representations
of the data from those representations
you will actually make that could be a
graph or a deep learning uh
model what we call
so to do this there is not one person is
suitable there are cloud is involved for
the training you would need lot of gpu
acceleration and stuff like that it is
physically impossible to have master all
the skills at one shot
so you need to be a very good
architect of the
hardware you need to bring the right
software tools so there are specialists
in each area but yes you can pick up
skills from all the areas that is what i
call ml architect or a generalist
and then
specialize on something so this that
term i use is typically a versatilist
so you have to be a specialist in one
area but you have to gain generalist
general knowledge about across the whole
pipeline so that you will become a
versatilist in the story then you can
develop multiple skills over the working
experience
so that is how it is you cannot
one person picking up everything is a
long drawn learning process
we do have some questions about
clarifying the relationship between
machine learning
deep learning and artificial
intelligence and and you call
this area machine intelligence which
implies that machine learning and
artificial intelligence are
are right fairly fairly integrated right
um right so
i understood the question so basically
there is a small distinction between
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
so what is the distinction is artificial
intelligence the moment we say ai
what comes is cognitive computing so
bringing a machine the ability to see
things that is called computer vision
bringing a mission the ability to uh
understand language that is nlp
this is ai
there is no uh intelligence derived from
it so intelligence that the machine
learning is something where a area to
kind of make machines learn looking at
examples this is where the algorithms
will come into the picture like gbm or
deep learning networks auto encoders etc
so what we try to do in machine
intelligence 4.0 is to bring these two
things together
so we focus on automation but at the
same time we focus on the
representational learning so basically
we wanted to convert or we wanted to
converge these two disciplines together
to make business impact so if you are a
researcher you can purely do ai robotics
research
how to make a robot more
functional how to how to move a
particular robotic arm more
naturally so that is the ai side of the
story
then the ml side of the story is more of
the gray cells whatever mind does right
so it will take all the data and try to
make a representation in the in the mind
and create you can call it as
associative learning
neural networks
are
the graph based learning graph neural
networks graph representation semantic
graphs etcetera
so that is how that is where the
distinction is
there is a scope for both fields but
there is much more impact when you bring
them together into my machine
intelligence for that
okay
um
we have a
question about
applying
uh machine intelligence to
digital marketing
and i think you touched on it in one of
your slides about
um
the notion of uh
product selling and that type of thing
but could you expand on that a little
right so basically the digital marketing
is a
optimization
of
how do you go and target a segment
so it is a
machine learning
it will come as segmentation so it is
known as customer segmentation
and there is something called as
propensity
so if i have a product of this features
and i have a group of
users with this kind of requirements
can i target this
particular product to those
people so
the features can change i may have
developed a slightly different product
so if if this product is sold somewhere
i can
sell this product or not
so the knowledge which is derived from
the historical information of what goes
together with what
can be used to target such and such
product such as such new product to such
and such new segment or create a segment
where to target
all these are predominantly known as
segmentation algorithms and propensity
algorithms so these algorithms can be
used mi and machine intelligence can
help your digital marketing
um campaigns
that kind of relates to
a couple of questions that came in from
people in other areas
so
the person who asked about digital
marketing is david who is interested in
knowing how an experienced digital
marketer would fit into machine
intelligence
we have a question from kasi
who is in civil engineering and would
like to to
consider a shift into
ml and ai
and we have a question from uh
naga who uh
who
is in software quality
um so you look at these people from
different
domains
yeah yeah and um
go
yeah i mean
what would you comment on on the
transition from
different domains into machine learning
and what strengths should these people
um
focus on bringing into the field yes yes
so
there are two as i said there are two
streams
so if you are people are coming from a
domain either it is a
qa testing or
from a digital marketing whatever it is
so there is a current way of working
things right there is a campaign being
done
there is a present way this is how i
will do my work
here
if you wanted to shift into a data
scientist role you have to look at a
logical solution how this task can be
improvised optimized
using data as the ingredient okay my
historical data i will take i will take
this external source of the data by
bringing in these data streams together
i can achieve this in a different way i
can actually reach to more people
by using this kind of additional data
maybe feeding this social
input into this my current campaign
model and then taking it to on that
channel so you optimize a channel or you
you become a
solution person so you find solutions to
the day-to-day problems you are facing
in your operations
then try to find a
try to find the intelligent solution
which is derived from the data then you
can come into experimenting with a
database experiment
and become a data scientist to pick up
some tools or programming languages auto
ml tools or whatever it is because you
there are absolutely no code machine
learning available
there are
studios and stuff like that you show
your data you just ask the studio to
develop the model and give the results
to you it will give the result if you
can interpret those results and use
those results in your business process
you can
term yourself as a data scientist and
help your business grow
using data
so this is the session i will give you
you don't try to come to a technical
learning python writing code
doing something if you are coming from
especially from another field into this
thing
but if you are already in technology you
know one programming language it is
better to pick up python better to pick
up few
um
a few tensorflows and white arches kind
of a thing then become an engineer to
develop the systems so development of
the systems is a different carrier than
defining what is to be developed
that is the data scientist
hope that answers this combination of
questions not specific to one question
but yeah
and and you had
touched in your in your presentation a
couple of times about
a distinction between a data scientist
and a machine intelligence machine
learning engineer
and the
different focuses of the two
disciplines could you um
kind of go back to that and
reiterate that or clarify that again
uh on the difference between the data
scientist and the
aml engineer right
yeah i mean it is
you you did make a distinction between
those two paths and and
so if you can
kind of so from a business analyst to a
data scientist it is more logical
solution uh logical uh solutioning in
the sense when we
look at what algorithms
you can use and how you can derive that
inference
for an example if i am
doing a market risk
kind of a requirement i wanted to
understand
how risky is a given market there are
currently a set of calculations there
are currently some methods are used to
say
okay this is the market risk i am in i
have invested on four different assets
and each asset has so much risk
and what is my total risk how much i can
take so there is a known calculation
but
there could be a new sources giving some
additional information to us so there
may be some news articles which are
coming in talking about that company
are they getting into some kind of a
legal troubles or what i think is the
best possible asset probably may not be
the best possible asset with the
emergence of new information new streams
of information
so if i pick that stream of data
add another risk factor to it and
create a new model altogether this is
the data science so i am looking at an
opportunity of having availability of
new stream of data and making use of
that in my business process so i am
improving my business process my
understanding of this market risk
adding one more dimension to it
so now comes ml engineer ml engineer
what he will do he will pick up that
news feed convert the text into set of
tokens
write a program to make it
understandable and give that score
saying that this is now 8.9 or this is
now 9.6 or this number comes into the
picture
so to do this plumbing
uh and actually getting it to this
number is
one
stream of carrier and taking this
defining this number and using this
number in how do i use this number in my
decision making
is the data scientist rule so now i need
a new number now i wanted to get one
more number that is what he will define
once that is defined the right source is
defined from converting that source to
this target is the engineering job
hope
with this example people will understand
what is these two distinctions
yeah
um
so we have
janavi who
is studying
uh machine learning and taking steps
towards becoming a machine learning
engineer
so his question specifically is after
learning some models of machine learning
what would be the next step towards
developing a machine learning engineer a
career should start with nlp or
should he go to
dsa or what are the what is the
you know what are the steps
having having understood some models
the next step for ml engineer
is to get on with some ml ops so how do
you
track your experiments how do you train
your models with different hyper
parameters when you are training these
models how do you store those models
automatically then how do you choose the
right model finally then
package and deploy it make it as a api
so that somebody can consume this so if
you develop that skills you can become a
ml engineer end to end so
uh
for a ml engineer it is not really
important to know all possible
algorithms and how to
make best accuracy
in an algorithm or best generalization
of learning in an algorithm all that a
machine learning engineer should know is
what are all the different types of
algorithms there are some standard
statistical algorithms there are random
forest and xg boost of a psychic learn
there are tensorflow keras models there
are pi touch models there are neural
networks so these are all multi-threaded
different types of models
these models can be stored in this way
they can be retrieved in this way they
can be trained in this way they can be
retrained in this way so that is the
skill you have to develop if you want to
get into a engineer
so the same thing if you wanted to
specialize on the data science you need
to take one set of algorithms like nlp
and develop more skills on the natural
language processing how do you deal with
mixed language how do you convert this
language into vector how do you do
natural language generation
summarization
what are all the generative networks
what are all the summaries gpt threes
what is happening in facebook what is
happening in google what is that robot
all that
all that
things so you can specialize on one
particular set of algorithms if you want
to be a more data scientist
or if you want to be an engineer you
have to take the pipelining tools you
have to take the tool a toolb tool c and
combine these tools and make it work on
a cloud or understand cloud architecture
combine that knowledge i think it
answers several questions about again
what are all the skills uh they have to
go with higher uh level of importance
yeah
i have an interesting question from
pasenjit who is uh looking at how how to
extract data from the internet um for
use in in
machine learning
machine intelligence right there are two
types of uh
extraction one is the scraping
so scraping is like you go on to the
internet like a with a bot and then go
and browse that site and keep getting
the data
there are data providers
who will do that work summarize the data
and provide for example there are news
feeds
they go through all the news
publications and summarize the data and
start giving you there is an amount of
money you pay to those provider and get
the data similarly market data feeds are
available so you go to your market and
get the feed
so there are two ways one doing it
yourself
write your own bot
go like a user ah
scan through that web page and get the
extracted data and then process it what
is there in it and keep moving
this is one manual way of collecting
some limited sites or sources or you can
use apis on twitter social media to get
the data
or you go and buy this
data products from a
from an aggregator people who aggregate
this data and sell it
okay
um and i think our exit question is
going to be for people who are
not in a technical background but would
like to
explore careers in machine intelligence
what would be the first preparatory
uh
training or courses that they should
take to to
develop that foundation and maybe assess
if they've got the aptitude for it
all right
so basically
machine intelligence or the machine
learning is training teaching so if you
want to teach a machine
to learn from examples this is what is
the core skill okay there is an example
data that is called labeled data so you
get that
this means this so it is a year to be
mapping is available
and now we wanted to make a machine
learn this
a means this b so this is what we want
to do
so um fundamentally it is
instead of saying
if this is equal to this
do this this is typical programming so
normally computer science carriers until
now are the programming careers people
have written huge long programs if you
see this kind of an input you do this as
an output so the people have developed
several things
how to show present it and everything
so the data story telling
so understanding data so it is more
about
understanding data if you can see data
you can fall in love with data
then
you can think about yes i can use this
data now i need tools to make some
insights out of this data so you should
be a data person first
some question i see in that why
freshers are asked to do data analysis
even if you want
if you don't know how to analyze data if
you don't know what is a correlation if
you don't know
if something is going up the other
variable is going up or not so whether
there is a dependency on two variables
or not
if you cannot do that
manually as i with human intelligence it
is very difficult to train a machine to
do it
so first we should know how to train
ourselves from the data so if i see few
facts i should be able to derive the uh
some
uh intelligence from those facts
the same guy applies
yeah
okay and and programming languages are
not the the
uh primary concern
in in
right so
uh very world uh
programming a world in the sense the
standard structured programming
languages like ce java
they can be used for some up to some
extent but predominantly the modern
functional languages
like
you can take
python kotlin haskell
all these things
what they give you fundamentally is you
can actually deal with a function
behavior as an attribute you can pass a
behavior to a function
and that function can use the behavior
and
learn itself and actually you can
you can self mutate your learning you
can return back your new behavior
so what is learning i have i have a way
of doing things
i see a new example contradictory to my
current understanding so probably how to
change my behavior how do i represent
this changing behavior
as a function
so if i can write a function
which can change its behavior
then that becomes a natural way of
programming for learning so that is
given by the functional programming
languages i don't give a specific
preference of python over
kotlin or haskell or something else
but
yes you need to have this functional
programming or
changing a behavior
by pro in a programmatic way i don't
need to intervene and rewrite the code
so if i have to rewrite the code like
that then we will be in the trouble so
hope that and that gives the
answer to the programming languages side
of machine intelligence yeah
i apologize for my cat uh crossing in
front of my camera there but um
but
i i did get just the last couple of uh
quick questions from
our live stream from youtube and
linkedin
um i think
one from linkedin ritchie
is asked if strong analytical skills are
required and i know that
you just answered that
so
i'll move on to the other one which is
from reynaldo on youtube
he just has a classification question
how did how do you know that the problem
that you're looking at
requires a machine intelligence solution
rather than just an algorithmic
um you know
standard
uh approach to programming
right so
when
the problem or the
issue with models are they are still
so you we show hundred examples and make
a
and create a model
so if we put this model somewhere this
model
is not moving
means it can only it has understood only
the past hundred examples
and it is predicting something
right so if that is okay if your hundred
examples cover the full gamut of things
you don't need any higher intelligence
is it clear so that is the clarity we
need to get but the real world is not
like that
daily new things are coming so if i
create a model
that model becomes stale next day
because some new data has come that are
new inferences can be drawn from this so
we need a continuous learning machine so
what we have to do is we have to create
an algorithm
or a sequence of algorithms
which can understand what it is
processing
intelligently decide whether it has seen
or not seen the data
learn from the data update itself as i
just said my behavior should
change with the presence of new data
after you ask the question
when i answer
this answer should go into the learning
and the question next question should be
a better than the same question so we
are not asking the same question again
that is what continuous learning needs
that is where mi4.o will come into the
use
so that is the simple decision you have
to whether you need a
simple decisioning engine
which you know all the input
combinations you can make a one
decisioning engine and
move with it but if you don't know there
are several unknowns there are fuzziness
in this still we want machine to process
the data that is where you need to bring
in
continuously learning machines
great um
so with that i'm going to apologize to
everybody who
whose questions i could not get to in
the time that we have we've already gone
a little bit over our hour so i want to
thank prasad for
his patience and generosity with his
time
and i'm going to
go ahead
and close out the webinar
with
another poll
and
this one asks people what are you most
interested in learning again if you're
watching on live stream i know you can't
answer the
poll through the
webex widgets so you can put in
your answers into your comments stream
on your
linkedin or youtube channel so
um
and
hold on a second let me launch this poll
i was on the wrong one
here we go
and we'll give about
a
half a minute for this
so we've talked about data science
artificial intelligence machine learning
and the you know the integration of the
two into machine intelligence
talked about data engineering and the
need to understand cloud computing
the need to understand devops and
related fields of mlaps
devsecops things like that
and
project management has a meta skill
involved with that
so these are some of the areas
that relate to today's topic
or sort of
many other areas in digital economy
skills
but
i'm going to share the poll results now
and
not a surprise that
the
largest contingent of you are interested
in learning data science artificial
intelligence machine learning
and those skills so
it's also interesting to see that about
half of you are interested in starting
right away
and given that
so many of you are at school currently
that would mean that you're already in
the process
but
thank you for that
i'm going to
once again thank for assad for a
really excellent presentation and
discussion
and
i hope that everyone in the audience
got as much out of it as i did here is
his linkedin information i will
moment put that into the chat window
so that you can go ahead
and connect with him
yeah so you can
send me a message if you have any
specific questions letter on linkedin i
am
open available on linkedin
thank you very much
for
your wonderful anchoring this session
and the introduction which you have
given and everything uh nice uh doing
this
hopefully it has been useful to some of
the
people there is a lot of scarcity of
these skills real good skills so
normally what i see
is people know a bit of
python language a little bit
of you know
data science fundamentals few algorithms
that is where
we see people coming in
if they prepare themselves more into the
mlaps little deep into the deep learning
it will be very useful when they come
into the industry
and
we can make the best use of
training the machines making missions
intelligence thereby the whole world
better
the fourth generation of industry and
the globalization a better place
for everyone in all the fields so that
is what
we are looking for a better set of
skills more quality
uh people coming into this uh carrier
thank you so much very much yeah
and uh
to know let everybody know that i have
dropped into the chat a link to
simply learns
training courses and programs so that
you can check those out
and i'm also putting in the link now to
our next
webinar next week which is a general
career webinar
um by a
leading career advisor and career coach
uh lieutenant colonel from vos
and it's on secrets of successfully
navigating potential career pitfalls
because as we
envision our career going forward
wherever we are from the pressure to the
experienced professional we have an idea
of
what's next for us and how we're going
to take the next step in our career and
then something else happens the real
world intervenes
and as the
musician john lennon once said life is
what happens when you're making other
plans
so this session is about
how to
anticipate some of those
pitfalls but also how to deal with them
when they do arise
and i think it's a valuable session for
you so
we hope to see you next week
and we hope to see you at future simply
learn
webinars and events and to welcome you
into our learning community you can
track us on social media at simply learn
on facebook and twitter and simply learn
on linkedin and with that
before my cat knocks over my webcam i
will
end the webinar but thanks again to
prasad and to everybody for being here
and
we'll see you soon
you